-This is very exciting.
You guys have a new talk show.
I can't wait.
One of the things you've said
is you don't want guests
who are just on
to promote their project.
-That's right.
-I would like to note
you are on my show right now
promoting your project.
-That is true. But as a --
Listen, as a father --
-The answer to that
is we are hypocrites.
-And also, as a father, I will
say, "Do as I say, not as I do."
-Okay. Gotcha.
-I mean, just 'cause we're
in the pocket of big tobacco
doesn't mean that we sold out.
-Oh, you've already sold out
to big tobacco?
-Yeah, bro. Phillip Morris --
-Kids, keep smoking
those Juul pods.
-You know what I'm saying?
Juuls, bro!
Can't be cool without a Juul!
-Bing!
-Very exciting. You have --
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
is on your show.
Also from the Bronx,
which is really exciting.
And you went down to D.C. and
shot a little with her there.
You went and visited her there.
How was it being with someone
from the same place as you
in D.C.?
-Well, the wild part
about that was apparently
the Capitol Police
do not have a sense of humor.
-Okay.
-You can't just be walking down
to the White House, be like,
"Yerr," and not get shot.
So we had to tone that down
a little bit.
-There was a lot of,
"Uh, do you have permits?
Do you have a permit to be here?
Do you have a permit
to shoot here, sir?"
-Also, I don't know if you've
noticed, since, you know,
we've upgraded the networks,
my man's got a little heavy
with the jewelry.
-Had to go through
the metal detector six times.
-No. Did you feel
like the Capitol
had changed Ocasio-Cortez,
or did you feel like
you guys brought the Bronx
out of her when you were there?
-We definitely did.
-Definitely brought the Bronx
out of her.
She just leaned out of her
office door and delivered
the heartiest "Yerr"
I've ever heard.
You know what I'm saying?
-Did other people --
Because those are
pretty close quarters.
Were other people
in the Capitol a little --
Could they tell
you guys were there?
-Well, what's funny -- I did not
know if most people know this.
Mike Pence has a brother
that's a representative.
And surprisingly, we're filming
in front of his office,
and all of a sudden,
the Capitol Police comes
and asks us for a film permit.
-Yeah. I wonder why.
-Really?
-Hmm. Ya snitch.
-He's like,
"Desus and Mero are here.
They're gonna slander me.
-"Hey, Mike, they're here.
Tell Mama."
-Tell Mother.
Tell Mother to call."
[ Laughter ]
-There is so much --
-Shout-out to nepotism.
[ Laughter ]
-There's some -- You know,
there is some criticism
from within the halls
of Congress
that, you know, Ocasio-Cortez
is shaking things up.
Did you feel that? Do you feel
like she's having an impact?
-You know what it is? It's
because Congress is just so old.
It's, like, antiquated
old rules, stodgy.
-Stodgy old dudes.
-And then you got a New Yorker.
And you know us New Yorkers.
We like to be very frank
and very straight,
so they're not used to her.
She's a little rough
around the edges,
but I think she's
getting stuff done,
and it's making them
a little nervous.
-One of the things that...
[ Cheers and applause ]
She was working on --
You know, she was not a fan
of the Amazon deal.
Amazon has now pulled out.
How do you guys feel about
Amazon pulling out
of this New York deal?
-When you say "pull out,"
it's triggering for me,
'cause I have four children.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-He's thinking a whole different
type of pulling out.
-I apologize.
-I was like,
"What do you mean by that?"
-Withdrawn. Withdrawn.
-Thank you, thank you.
-I'm not mad at them
pulling out the Amazon deal.
And it's not, like,
because I love New York
and I'm worried about, like,
the culture and the community.
Jeff Bezos has too much money,
and I'd like to see him
take the L.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Humble him.
Listen.
You got $133 billion, man.
Relax.
-$170.
-Oh, wow. It's up to that now?
-It is up to that by
the last time you Googled it.
-Exactly. We don't need
another Amazon Center.
New York is crowded enough
as it is.
-Yeah.
-You know.
It bothered me, though,
because I like Amazon Prime.
Like, I just ordered
a panini maker
at 2:00 last night
for some reason.
But I can get around that.
-Okay. You can make it work.
-I ordered like four air
purifiers. I don't know why.
-They're like,
"Do you want them on Thursday?"
You're like, "Hell yes."
-I was like,
"Do I want a strawberry holder?
Of course I want
a strawberry holder."
-And I'm not waiting
until Monday for it.
-[Bleep] that.